[موسيقى
] تم الترويج له على أنه أكبر عرض في العالم
، وجنوبي دبي مباشرة من
بناء هذا الحدث جارية بشكل جيد
، ويبلغ حجم موقع معرض دبي إكسبو أكثر
من 600 ملعب كرة قدم ويقال
إنه أكبر حدث يقام على الإطلاق في
العالم العربي  على مدار ستة أشهر بدءًا من
أكتوبر ، ستعرض 192 دولة
الثقافة والابتكار ، ومن الواعد
أن تعرض بنية تحتية متطورة لا تصدق
وتكنولوجيا لم يسبق لها مثيل مع 25
مليون زيارة من المتوقع أن
تحقق دفعة كبيرة للاقتصاد
وفقًا لتقرير مستقل  تقرير من
شركة الاستشارات العالمية إرنست ويونغ
بين عامي 2013 و 2030 ، سيؤدي إلى رفع
اقتصاد البلاد بأكثر من
ثلاثة وثلاثين مليار دولار لدعم
خلق أكثر من 900 ألف فرصة عمل
وخلال هذا الحدث ستساهم بنسبة
واحد ونصف في المائة في الناتج المحلي الإجمالي السنوي
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
، من المقدر
أن تستفيد القطاعات المختلفة من هذا التعزيز الاقتصادي ،
وتحديداً معدل النمو الاقتصادي  صناعة etail ، FMB
، تشييد الطيران
وقطاعات الفنادق والضيافة التي
تعد من أفضل الصناعات التي تستفيد من
معظم الفنادق الجديدة ، يتم تشغيلها
مع 160.000 غرفة لتكون جاهزة في الوقت المناسب
لمعرض Expo 2020 في مجموعة ضيافة فاخرة
تضم أحد عشر فندقًا في جميع أنحاء  تقول دبي ،
بما في ذلك برج العرب الشهير ،
إنها جاهزة
تمارا ، فنحن نستعد للحقائق بحلول عام 2020
، ونعلم أن برج العرب
سيكون أحد أكثر الفنادق شهرة وفقدانًا
في السوق ، لقد
قدمنا فريقًا كاملاً من الموهوبين  طهاة جدد
كثير منهم يتمتعون بخلفيات نمط المهمة
حتى نعرف أنه يمكننا لماذا
جميع زوارنا بالإضافة إلى ذلك ، قمنا
بتعزيز عدد عقاراتنا من
خلال التجديد الكامل من خلال استضافة هذا
الحدث العالمي ، وتأمل دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة أن يترك
إرثًا اقتصاديًا دائمًا
مكانة راي دبي العالمية
كوجهة سياحية رائدة Jon dove
tereus CNN Devon
you